a former police officer in North
Carolina faces assault charges after
body camera video appears to show him
beating a man accused of jaywalking this
footage was leaked to the Asheville
Citizen Times it shows then officer
Chris Hickman allegedly hitting and
tasing Johnny Jermaine rush Hickman was
arrested yesterday
mark Strassmann is in Asheville outside
the bun cone County Sheriff's Department
mark good morning good morning Hickman's
arrest comes two months after he
resigned from national police and more
than six months after his alleged
assault of rush but people here want to
know why that arrest took so long when
the incident was caught on tape he has
two nicely to stop body cam video shows
the confrontation between vent officer
Chris Hickman and Johnny Jermaine rush
put your hands behind your back after a
brief scuffle rush takes off a black
male white tank top thinks it's funny
you know what's funny our core on the
ground
once Hickman and another officer catch
up to rush
Hickman appears to hit him in the head
repeatedly then tase him the
confrontation took place last August
Asheville police say they received a
use-of-force complaint and removed
hitman from patrol the next day then
launched an internal affairs
investigation and informed the district
attorney the DA's office says it shows
not to file charges in September so the
investigation could continue in December
police returned with three new videos
related to officer Hickman's use of
force he resigned in January I don't
understand why the DA didn't bring
charges community members this week
grilled Asheville officials at a packed
Town Hall meeting we are no longer where
the 2000
Asheville Police Chief Tami Hooper did
not try to defend Hickman's behavior and
admitted her department is under
scrutiny I'm happy to resign if that's
gonna solve the problems here but some
people left the meeting with more
concerned I don't know that we got a lot
of questions answered though about the
timeframe when think when people knew
and didn't know
Hickman left jail last night after
reportedly posting a ten thousand dollar
bond we weren't able to reach him or to
reach rush and bianna this case is now
going on with the cooperation of both
the FBI and state investigators so many
questions remain mark thank you